any of you have heard of m26 okay anyone
it's a custom already okay alright for
those of you that don't know and 26
that's the company I work for and we're
mobile bank based in Germany and we're
in a mission to build the first bank
you'll love when it's off - in two words
you don't really find in the same
sentence one of the reasons we like to
be very proud about what we do is
actually investing into the user
experience to make every day dealing
with finances really easy and one of our
signature products is actually called
spaces which is really about how you can
manage money and easy sort of
drag-and-drop fashion through your
mobile device the role that I play in 26
is the chief scientist I know is the
former CTO and the chief scientist role
is allowing me to spend a lot more time
sort of speaking and writing about what
we do technology wise because we do have
some offices and we have an office in
Barcelona that's growing that might be
relevant for some people here but
today's talk is really focused on one of
the books that have produced call
talking with tech leads so over my
career I've worked for technology in
about sort of 20 years almost and one of
my passions is really helping sort of go
on their journey from being an engineer
to leading and managing and throughout
my career I've helped a lot of people
talk to them and found out what were
some of their challenges but also helped
people get on to that sort of next level
up and try to understand what it is that
you have to do differently if you're
leading out of interest who here is
already sort of leading so if you're an
architect lead developer tech lead ok so
this will be very relevant and for those
of you who want you may be considering
what it means to be one of these and
it's actually often a surprise if you
probably taught so people here in this
room who've maybe just started into this
or they reflect on their first
experience it's a very big shock to the
system about what you're supposed to do
and often a lot of companies don't
really support people on that journey
and so this is kind of a lot of the talk
I'll be covering which kind of touches
upon some of the things that I do with
teaching people about what it means to
be a lead developer or a tech lead and
we'll be sharing some of those
experiences so today will be going on a
little bit of a journey and we'll be
starting to sort of first look at what
it's the archetypical story of how do
people like yourselves find yourself in
this role as a lead
deaf and what's that experience like I
wouldn't be clear about what is what I
mean by a tech lead so one observation
that I have is every company is very
different and how you want to label
something so we're not consistent as an
industry about titles and what
responsibilities are but at least during
the talk we'll hopefully have a good
shared understanding about what I mean
when I talk about a tech lead part of
the journey is also understanding what
are the surprises and struggles that
you'll find along the way so like
everything we learn and part of the
learning experience is often finding out
things that we've never dealt with
before and then finally some tools that
will equip you to be a much more
effective leader particularly a more
effective technical leader and that I
think will make you a lot more
successful along the way we'll also be
highlighting some lessons learnt as a
nice way of sort of summarizing some key
learning points in this talk so let's
start off with what I talked about as a
typical story now I've trained over
hundreds of sort of different types of
tech leads and passion is very
consistent what often happens is like
yourselves you probably started off as a
individual contributor or developer
writing code building features learning
frameworks learning languages and you
know delighting in the things that you
create the impact that you have on users
and just that constant buzz of actually
learning and at some point of the way
there's kind of two shifts so sometimes
you get recognized by people in your
sort of industry or your sort of company
or you might have an internal drive and
you say actually I want the next
challenge I want to be promoted and
maybe being recognized by other people
they say actually I think you're ready
to try something else we'd like you to
have more responsibility we'd like you
to have more impact and so we want to
sort of put you into a role that will
allow you to do that and this is
actually very connected to what often
people talk about as a career ladder or
a career pathway and I'll come back to
this in a second but I want you to be
sort of first thinking about actually
this sort of improved impact in this
improved sort of role isn't actually a
sort of step up in the ladder and we'll
come back to that as to why now what
happens with a lot of people when they
get this promotion or this title is that
they go back to their computer and they
start doing what they did as an engineer
right so I'm gonna take a story I'm
gonna take a feature I'm gonna go fix
and right
all of this stuff now I get to make all
the hard tough decisions and now that I
have this label you know the question
that they start to ask themselves over
time is what am I supposed to do
differently I have a new title and you
roll but what does that actually
translate to what do I do differently
and what should I be thinking about so
lesson one that I'd like you to really
come away with is recognizing that this
tech lead role is not a promotion it's a
role change and so it's really important
to think about this because it's not
really more of the same things that
you're doing before with more influence
or seniority it's actually a different
set of skills and responsibilities and
this is where it's really important to
come back to this idea of a career
ladder now we're a startup and one of
the great things about joining a
start-up is that you could just shape
and change things and we've been going
through a cycle of trying to create
Clara promotion pathways and
expectations around roles and
responsibilities so for those of you who
aren't familiar with a career ladder
normally its kind of describing
different types of roles at different
levels and you often talk about the
behaviors or the responsibilities
associated with that level and then the
idea of higher levels have greater
impact right so a c-level has impact
across the organization an individual
contributor has like an impact over the
system that they're working on and so
I've learned some things about working
with a career ladder and developing one
so one of them is it's not a complete
checklist so if you go I do this I do
this I do this therefore I'm ready for
this sort of role it's not intended to
be a checklist where you do these things
right so everyone is different here
every circumstance is different every
team is different and so these kind of
career frameworks are there to have some
sort of shared expectations generalities
so this is really useful if you talk
about a shared system which is a guide
for a conversation right so every
company will be different every team
will be different and so it's important
to have some shared expectations but
it's not comprehensive because everyone
in this room is different and you have
to account for the differences for
people and the systems in which they
work in and a really good reason to have
something like this as well if you don't
have anything like this
it helps to reduce systemic bias so once
again if you don't have anything like
this career framework what often happens
is you have some manager that goes yeah
I think you're ready for a promotion but
it's all built into gut feel and that
means biases right and so it comes back
to actually explicit expectations that
shared understanding about what it means
to be different roles and what is
expected from those different roles so
the normal sort of career journey when
people start off as an engineer is they
they might join the industry as a sort
of junior software developer right so
they're learning their first programming
language they're learning how to you
know write clean code your unit tests to
structure systems really well and as
they grow and expand and build
experience they might graduate to a
place where they don't need as much
support they can be a lot more
independent they can take a feature
without too much support from everyone
they can start to sort of know where to
reach out to learn more items and then
they might start to become a sort of
senior software engineer right they
might start to mentor one or two other
engineers they become a more of a go-to
person for bit particular types of
knowledge and they maybe start to take
care of smaller systems or services
independently and so a lot of people
start thinking well this tech lead or
lead developer is like this extra step
up and this is where things start to go
wrong wrong expectations now I've done a
lot of studies about career ladders and
the way that people explain them and if
you're familiar particularly with the
u.s. sort of model they often talk about
two-track career pathway so this is very
popular in places like Google and
Facebook and Twitter where they talk
about making sure that you have
promotion or career pathways for
technical people as well as for
management and so they often talk about
a two-track
sort of career path I actually argue
it's two's not enough and actually a
better model that I like to describe
it's actually a trident model of career
evolution so you do have a really pure
sort of individual contributor track and
I don't think a lot of organizations
need significant levels of individual
contributors at higher levels but you
definitely have impact of being a
technical leader and you can do that
without having to do management right
and management is like a whole
separate skillset and responsibilities
of which you are accountable for and I
actually like to describe separating
them now of course this is a model and
so what this means is that every
organization will be bit differently so
some organizations will blur management
and technical leadership together so if
any of you for instance work in an
engineering management role often I ask
the question is are you responsible for
system design and quality because often
that's an overlap with the technical
leadership and we'll come to that in a
little bit but I think it's really key
to sort of think about you know for a
role in a different level in which
tractors that are belong to you and
therefore where should the focus for
that role relateable belong to and so if
we come back to a sort of mental model
of we see tech leads as another step up
I would actually argue that it's
actually a step across into this
technical leadership track right so you
have engineering managers purely more on
the management side around people
process hiring you know compensation
dealing with personal issues you have
individual contributors who might be
more specialists right so technologists
who are very deep in a particular area
that you can drop in in problems solve
certain types of things but they're
still ultimately individually
contributing and then you have a whole
category of technical leadership which
is leading a broader technical topics so
if we could delve into each of these
tracks I would argue that if you look at
the time where people spend what they do
and the majority of it individual
contributors spend 70 to 80 percent of
their time sort of executing or doing
right this is the the great thing that
you love as an engineer of getting into
that flow of like solving problems and
you're sort of mostly writing and doing
things at your laptop so you know it
might be about designing and drawing
mental pictures or trying to understand
how you architect something to solve a
particular problem it's often about
testing the solution that you have and
of course writing code in our sort of
field if we look at management I have to
describe effective management as
managing the system in which everyone is
working so you tend to lead people and
manage the system and that's how I like
to describe the differences so some of
the activities that managers will spend
a lot of their time doing will be doing
things like supporting people so does a
team have all of access to the
information perhaps dependencies or
resources they need to be successful or
do they need somebody to sort of go and
work with other departments or teams to
try to make sure that they have all the
things that they need to be effective
it's often about planning right so as
you as your organization gets bigger you
have expectations about what your team
is going to be delivering if it's on
track or if it's not interacting making
sure that people are communicating
effectively across organizations so
there's no surprises as part of that in
a lot of places there's budgeting things
right so it might be about headcount or
it might be about the amount of money
that you can spend on sort of training
or tooling and trying to manage some
sort of budget and often about sort of
organizing so thinking about is the team
set up for success are we sort of
growing the team too large and therefore
we need to actually split the team into
two teams for them to be a lot more
effective so this is often about
managing the environment of which people
work in now the third track that I want
to focus on is really about this
technical leadership track and what I
talk about is often leading technical
teams and topics so part of this might
be about aligning the team right so this
morning we've heard about making sure
that architectures architects think
about a technical vision and this is
really about an event alignment right
that everyone individually contributing
is working towards that consistent
technical vision it's often about
technical risk management as well and we
learned from Russ's talked earlier chaos
engineering is actually about fighting
where are the potential risks and issues
that are underlied and sort of waiting
to be surfaced as part of your complex
system it's often about making sure that
there is an articulated technical vision
are we building a module or eyes
monolith or are we building a
distributed set of services and if so
how are we building those services how
do we know do we create a new service or
do we add things to an existing service
there needs to be some idea about this
at a higher level and making sure that
everyone has the similar mental model
around that with a lot of systems that
are you know around for a long time
there's obviously learnings to be made
and mistakes that have been made and so
you have technical debt and an art to
making sure that you can continue to
evolve systems is that you make sure
that you're sort of strategically
managing what
technical debt you have and knowing when
to perhaps react attacked a piece of a
component or perhaps react attack to
sort of the boundary between the two
services to improve delivery and being
out to be a lot more effective in our
industry it's also making sure that
technical knowledge is spread across the
team right so we don't end up in a
situation where one person can't go into
holidays because the team is completely
dependent on them for them to make
changes to one part of the system all we
don't want that person to always have to
be attached to a on call or a telephone
so they can actually take a holiday
right and there's so much stuff because
our system is constantly evolving we're
constantly adding things to a code base
where we need to transfer not only what
has been built but also the tools of how
we've built them and the decisions that
we've made along the way and somebody
needs to sort of foster this spread of
technical knowledge so a top tip for any
of you who've been doing this is really
a really understanding that what got you
here won't get you there and so the
things that you experienced as a
developer all the time you spent on
things like writing code writing clean
code testing aren't exactly the same
skills that will make you effective as a
leader of technical people it's
important that you understand the nature
of that but they're very different skill
sets so that's a really important
takeaway is that you shouldn't reward
yourself for the things that you were
being rewarded before as an individual
contributor but actually see your role
quite differently and you'll need to
develop different skills so we'll move
on to what I talked about is what are
what is this role and then what are the
skills associated with that so let's
talk about what I mean by what is a tech
lead so I have a small definition and
it's basically a person who was a
software engineer responsible for
leading a development team and
responsible for the quality of the
technical deliverables right so there's
a difference between I've seen really
good engineering managers where their
background is perhaps project management
or Quality Assurance but they don't know
about code right they don't know how to
structure code they don't understand the
trade-offs when you make a decision an
architectural a significant decision
about how to facilitate that and so
that's where a person who was a tech
lead needs to have that back
in being a software engineer now it
seemed really successful tech leads also
not necessarily be software engineers in
the programming background but they
understand the principles of
architecture and design to help teams
make better choices the other side of
this is responsible for the quality of
the software internally right so this is
a really easy thing to miss because
somebody needs to be taking care of it
and business people are assuming that
all of you here are the professionals
that are taking care of this software
quality but sometimes we make mistakes
and learn along the way and so we have
to somebody has to be championing
investment into managing that quality
and making sure it's the right level of
quality right and so the tech leave is
this role that is responsible for the
team making sure that everyone's leading
together and also responsible for the
quality of the technical deliverables
now if we look at the sort of skill
overlap some of the different things
that you really want to focus on are
these three different sort of circles so
as an individual contributor you would
have focused a lot on what is this sort
of development skills sort of circle
right so these are all the things that
we talked about you're writing new
features you know how to break things
down into smaller elements you know how
to continuously deliver and deploy
different elements and you might get
some experience with some architecture
right you might have a chance actually
you build a new system and design some
of those interfaces you might get to
work on a more complex feature that
requires you to do a lot more
architectural thinking but it's rare in
my experience that developers get
explicit support in building leadership
skills and so a good tech lead needs a
really good balance across all of these
three different attributes and the
question for a lot of people here is how
much support do you get from your
organization when you first stepped into
this role how many people were teaching
you leadership skills how many people
were supporting with architectural
training to get you ready for this right
you wouldn't have experienced this
naturally as part of your role as an
individual contributor but you need
these skills to be effective as a tech
lead so listen to is that you know the
tech lead role requires strong
leadership skills now the way that I
like to explain this
if you imagine that you have some sort
of game like an RPG right you get
experience points that you can allocate
different skill sets based on what you
do and a lot of the time you would have
allocated all your points to being a
really great developer because that's
the stuff that you like you might have
had some of that experience being an
architect but you need some more in
order to graduate to that next level of
being really effective and perhaps you
took some acts of leadership but often
there's a big gap between what it's
needed and where you have allocated
those points so the question is how do
you bridge these gaps if you need these
to be effective where do you start so
some really great tips of advice
practical is firstly first step is
always awareness and this is a really
great thing that you're all here today
so you know that the gap to be filled
right the second one is to try to find
training that is relevant and I think
this is the really great thing about
particularly leadership is that it's a
field that affects all types of
businesses out there when you're
starting to lead and there's a lot of
writing that's out so you know get
yourself into training courses there's a
lot of different things out there for
different types of leadership skills and
make sure that you invest your time
training yourself on these things rather
than training yourself on the next to
newest greatest technology the next step
to actually apply your training is make
sure you get some coaching or mentoring
so get some support along the way so
that you have some feedback effectively
about what you've learnt and then how
you're applying it and what other ways
that there are of actually growing there
as well and the fourth step is really
making sure you practice right so the
hard thing about practicing leadership
skills and this is some of the
awkwardness that I think comes along
with it is that you sometimes feel
awkward because you're dealing with
people and when you make a mistake you
kind of think it's gonna be a really bad
mistake because other people will suffer
but it's really the only way of being
able to develop leadership skills is by
actually practicing like we do with code
cutters like we do with writing features
all the time for software is that you
have to develop explicitly the practice
areas right so you can find lots of ways
to do this if you're thinking about you
know how you communicate things you can
run little workshops with your team to
practice each of these things but
deliberately practice really key
tippers put in terms of growing your
leadership skills and so when you sort
of think about your personal development
and as you move into this role or if
you're thinking about moving into this
role it's very tempting to sort of
double down on you know building those
development skills so learning about all
these tools that you're hearing about
but the emphasis if you really want to
be successful is to shift where you put
your focus to make sure there's an equal
balance across all of these different
areas it doesn't mean that you have to
have great expertise in all of these at
the same time that'll be impossible I
guarantee you but it's really important
that you find a nice balance between
leadership architecture and development
all right a question that I get a lot
from when I'm training in tech leads is
do you need to be the best developer I
know I actually say no it's by
definition you won't be the best
developer because you're sort of working
across all your sort of engineers and
you'll lose a lot of information because
everyone else is also adding and
changing systems as well and actually
one of the biggest things that you can
have is change your mental model of
instead of rewarding yourself through
the code that you write you think about
the code that you've Mabel you've been
able to enable through your team and if
they're producing better quality
software that's kind of an environment
that you've enabled as well right and so
this is kind of one of those mental
model shifts another question that I
often get is as an in as a tech lead how
much coding time should I actually have
now I will say firstly engineers don't
spend a hundred percent of their time
coding you all have to talk to each
other you all have to probably hopefully
showcase the work that you're doing and
talk to users and find out what you
should be doing so you'll never ever be
a hundred percent at your keyboard and
yes we have meetings like retrospectives
and planning's to make sure that we're
all on track and improving right so 100
percent is impossible for all engineers
but what should I technically be
estimating their time approximately with
code I have a rule of thumb which sort
of says it's about 30 percent of time so
if you think about a week it's about a
day and a half
right and I would say it's a minimum so
it doesn't mean that like you have to
always hit 30 percent but you need to
think about your averages so for
instance as you kick off a new project
or a new initiative
you'll probably get drawn away from the
team in terms of planning sessions or
workshops with other teams but what
that's telling you is that there's a lot
of things that have changed in that time
frame on your codebase that you probably
need to catch up on when you come back
to your team right and different tech
leads have different ways of actually
approaching how they keep in touch with
the DES code some people like to pay a
program and so a really great way is
that you know if they're working with
somebody they've sat down they've
discussed how they're going to approach
something and then when they get drawn
away to a meeting they're confident that
thing will continue going right so it's
not going to be sort of stopped because
somebody has to go to a meeting and then
when they come back from that meeting
they can sort of catch up on what's
happened and then things kind of keep
going other tech leads like to do things
like review pull requests or the sort of
source couldn't control I would say you
have to be a bit careful with that one
because sometimes people feel like
they're being observed and you don't
want to sort of be too overzealous with
feedback when you say hey what's this
commit about but you know that's a good
way of sort of getting a sense of how
the codebase is evolving over time and
is there any significant change that you
want to have the important thing about
this is really trying to understand what
is the shape of the codebase and how is
it evolving as a team and so a really
good test of an effective tech lead is
to sort of think about just the codebase
look like it was written by a single
person now it never will I can guarantee
you that even you yourself will develop
a style of code that changes over time
and you know when you kind of look at
code it's not about does it look exactly
the same but if you kind of squint and
you look at the shapes of code you look
at the patterns that's the consistency
that you want to have a good way of sort
of having a look at this is that if you
open up one part of the codebase and you
look at some files do you find very long
classes with very long methods or do you
go to another part of the codebase and
you open it up with very short methods
and very functional styles because
that's giving you information about how
not aligned your team is with how
they're working on the same sort of
system and so this is a really nice
heuristic of sort of testing yourself as
an effective lead there seeing how well
does the team actually
like a single entity how well is it at a
team or is it just a group of
individuals all contributing their
individual styles to a codebase right so
if you're effective you're shepherding
the team in a consistent manner everyone
could will solve problems very
differently but it's important to make
sure that there's a understood way of
sort of contributing codes so code
Styles or the patterns that you reach
for for solving types of problems so you
know do we use the same way that we
access the database or do we have for
persistence frameworks as a result so
you look for the common commonalities
and you can facilitate that now I talked
a little bit about leadership skills
before and there's a lot of them out
there so these are only just a few of
them and what's really fascinating about
this is that each of these sort of areas
have full bodies of knowledge and
research around them so you can sort of
obsess and get in and you know involved
in all of these different areas and the
next slide you'll want to take a photo
of because these are all the books that
I would often recommend if you want
actually go and you know read something
that will make you a lot more effective
so these are some of my favorite books
that I have to talk about if you want to
become a really great leader these are
the ones that you'd add to your Kindle
or your wish list and and find ways to
actually practice each of these
different things it's one of those
things where a lot of developers aren't
really talked aren't really sort of
pointed at so when you find yourself in
a leadership role you don't know where
to go so this is a really good benefit
because now you know here are some
places they can go read and I really
like this quote which talks about
reading is still the main way that I
both learn new things and test my
understanding any guesses who it comes
from anyway sorry no one no guesses what
was that no not for me no no
so quite relevant to the dot note anyone
it's Bill Gates so you know someone
who's been in technology so long it's
still continually reading and you know
absorbing bodies of knowledge and it's
like one of those things that I talk
about in sort of hyper growth learn is
that when you write stuff down it scales
out much better right it's not so as
interactive as a talk or a panel
discussion
but it allows people to access knowledge
and there's so much knowledge out there
about leadership skills that you can tap
into that's really waiting for you to
sort of get out there so lesson three
though is really making sure that you
know there are many resources but be
sure to really practice right so I do
this and I suffer from this as well I
read a whole book and then I don't apply
any of it and it kind of becomes
interesting but what's really useful is
when you actually take something from
that book and you practice that right so
you put it into deliberate practice and
you say out of the book I would like to
try three new things and do things
differently right and then you'll find
your own style about what works for you
but I often encourage people to sort of
build your leadership toolkit invest in
doing that and then find what works for
you one of the things that you'll find
is that everyone is a little bit
different in so you have to build a very
broad toolkit to be a lot of effective
in lots of different teams and
structures so hopefully you understand
what I mean by a tech lead let's talk
about some of the surprises and
struggles and for me this was a really
interesting thing as I was interviewing
a lot of people for the book is that I
interviewed people who are very new to
the role so novices as I talk about them
stepping into that role and then people
who have been playing this role for a
very long time and there came to be kind
of similarities particularly with a
group of novices and these are the
things that hit you the first time you
do this these are the unknown unknowns
right and these are some of the things
that were kind of talked about and will
cover three specific surprises and
struggles that I'm sure many of you will
recognize or maybe you're you will start
to recognize over the next year or two
so the first one I kind of like picture
with a group of people and there's kind
of one person on the outside and when
you step into this role for the first
time one of the common surprises or
struggles that you'll have is the sense
of being alone as an engineer you are
surrounded by other people in the same
spot right you get into a rut you can
turn to another engineer and say hey
like I'm stuck on this like thing can
you help me and they'll come along and
they'll look at the code and then
they'll give you some ideas you have
other people in that similar situation
to you but when you're the lead the tech
lead you're there probably by yourself
right and this is kind of normal and so
you start to get a sense of feeling like
an outsider the relationship changes
sometimes when you're working with
people and you get that promotion and
that suddenly you can't be exactly the
same sort of friend relationship because
you're also responsible for the rest of
the team and this just kind of comes
with any leadership role is that when
you step into that role is that there
are sort of information things that
you'll have access to that perhaps you
don't want to necessarily share with
everyone perhaps it's a personal issue
with one person on your team that it
would be not right to share that
information with everyone else and so
you feel kind of guilty because you're
trying to be transparent but you also
don't want to upset somebody else you
want to respect somebody else's privacy
right there's another sort of role that
you play as lead which is trying to sort
of shield or filter information from the
team so you you're always trying to find
a way to sort of keep the team protected
from noise so that everyone can focus on
what they're doing but at the same time
you're trying to be transparent and make
sure everyone has the right context of
what they have and finding this balance
is never perfect like you really
struggle to always find am I being
transparent enough and you know these
are things that you alone will have to
choose and therefore it's natural to
feel by yourself right and this is a
very normal journey that everyone goes
on when they find themselves in this
role the second surprise and struggle
that a lot of people find themselves
kind of depicted by this thing with lots
of different errors and a lot of this is
really about uncertainty right what's
really fascinating by us is that you
know we are often looking for that right
answer alright and we're kind of trained
to do this through the stuff that we
we've developed as engineers right we
have this binary habit this test goes
red or green alright I deploy the
systems working or not working like I
have these things where it's like the
right thing because it works or it
doesn't work at all and so we develop
these habits thinking that everything is
always a yes or a No or that there's a
right answer and a wrong answer and one
of the challenges between this role is
that you're always dealing with
imperfect information right people's
preferences for what they would like to
work on will change over time
I've worked with lots of teams and you
know one of the things that a lot of
engineers often say is that I want to
work at an interesting thing right and
you talk to all people your team and
everything will be very different when
you ask what is interesting for you
right and so you're always dealing with
that uncertainty because you can't read
it into other people's minds and you're
dealing with the imperfect information
what was interesting for somebody before
will slowly become less interesting as
they do more of it and so that changes
over time as well and so you know you
often struggle we're trying to think
about am I making the right decision or
is it the best thing that I'm trying to
do and you know it's a struggle there
everyone deals with again and it never
goes away and it's really hard because
as an engineer you want correctness you
want certainty but in this role you
often won't write the architectural
decision about which direction that you
go you may not feel the effects for some
time as well right it's a bit like you
hypothesize it's the right direction but
you never know until other events kind
of happen um the third surprise and
struggle is kind of depicted by this
kind of snowflake and hopefully most of
you might guess where this come from
strong and I like to describe that
people are puzzling all right
snowflakes because snowflakes are unique
and people are unique and this is really
interesting because when you work with
people you get to both appreciate the
differences and maybe you get frustrated
by the differences as well but you have
to start to realize that actually
because everyone is unique you have to
work with them in different styles
according to yourself and themselves and
how they work together as a team one
thing that I have to encourage people to
think about is not look at uniqueness as
a problem but look at the different
strengths so people are unique because
they bring different properties and they
have different skills and experiences
and that's one of the reasons we work as
a team it's because as a team you have
much broader access to all of these
strengths and properties but there will
require good leadership to sort of
steward them as you work with more
people you might just start to pick up
different types of patterns as well and
I would encourage you to think about
archetypes rather than stereotypes so
series hyping is kind of thinking oh
I've seen this pattern by a pattern of
behavior before
I know how they're going to react and
that's the wrong attitude to have what
you should have is I've seen this
pattern before how might they react but
be prepared that they'll react quite
differently again because once again
people are unique and so when you start
to think about resolving conflict
between engineers or trying to give
information to your team you know some
individuals will maybe want information
through vocal and be told personally
other people will prefer to read it
other people will prefer to get sort of
updates or slack and other people will
prefer to go to a sort of confluence or
a wiki page and pull that information
you'll never get it right but make sure
that you understand there's different
ways of doing things and you often have
to do things multiple times in different
styles as you get to learn and
appreciate different people so people
are puzzling and this is also one of
those common surprises and struggles so
there's a lot of things that and these
are only the tip of the iceberg of some
of the commonalities of what you might
find yourself doing in a leadership role
but lesson 4 is really taking heart that
others have been on this journey right
so you're not the first person who does
this and other people struggle with this
as well and so a really great way of
dealing with this is actually building
your own sort of support structure so
even if you're that sort of only single
tech lead on your team
hopefully you work in an organization
that has other teams as well who have
other tech leads so reach out to them
and sort of say can we go for a coffee
for you let's go for lunch
swap experiences build up your own
network of people that you can go to and
say I'm having this issue with this
engineer I don't know how to deal with
them how would you deal with them like
how else have you resolved this conflict
between o2 engineers and made a decision
so build a support structure find people
that you can sort of lean against they
can sort of be a sort of mirror for
information and give you ideas about how
to do things in a different way it
doesn't mean it was right because once
again people will react differently but
least you have different styles of
dealing with things so there's some of
the surprises and struggles let's talk
about what it means to be a really good
tech lead and what are the some of the
tools that you can actually use to make
you even more effective so one of the
things to think about is rather than
thinking about developing code develop
others so they can write better code and
because we often think about this binary
habit we often think about well you know
when we're leaving other people there's
kind of two modes we can either tell
people what to do or we delegate once
again things aren't binary it's actually
a lot more refined and this is where I
talk to a lot of people about this
situational leadership model and it
talks about this model about thinking
about different styles of leading
depending on the situation and one of
the interesting things is sort of you
want to move from getting to a point
where you're sort of telling or being
more prescriptive in how to do something
so getting to a point where you build up
trust and understanding and confidence
that you can actually delegate and
throughout this process you have to
think about you know what is the task
that somebody's doing what is their
skill and experience what is their sort
of motivation right so a really good
example is you know somebody asked me to
set up a machine learning type of
project like I would want like a
step-by-step tutorial and be told what
to do it's not my background not my area
of expertise but I would be a beginner
in that situation and so I would want
somebody to be very prescriptive of that
sort of level however if somebody told
me okay Patrick go bill like a
distributed system back-end dealing with
all of this sort of transaction
information like you can just delegate
that to me right like I'll go talk to
the right people I'll try to understand
the characteristics of the system that's
my background I feel a lot more
comfortable doing that but you can't
sort of jump from one extreme to the
other you kind of have to build up
people's experience to make sure they do
that and so you know somebody who is
maybe starting off learning something
you might actually need to sell the
opportunity to people right help them
understand how it'll help them grow help
them understand why it's having an
impact and you might need to actually
get people's motivation of why they want
to actually contribute to this some
problems are actually really hard and
you can't sort of delegate that because
it's too complex and so this is actually
where you might need to participate so
you both need to actually work together
to solve a particular problem but once
you've sort of solved that type of
problem it becomes a known thing and
then the next time that you have that
you can actually delegate it as well
right so this is a really nice model
that sort of things about how do you
transition people to a part where you
growing people along the way to a point
where you can actually delegate more
things and it means that you get more
things done you probably have more time
than to go read code but it also means
that other people in your team are
actually growing developing and having
more impact themselves so it's a win-win
from both situations now the thing that
the situational leadership model talks
about is thinking about three
characteristics about understanding what
style of leadership you take so it might
be about sort of skill motivation and
urgency so if there's a production
incident you don't really want people to
say hey like what do you think could be
the problem you want somebody really
acting on it right so you kind of need
to be a lot more directive and that's
the urgency
you know if it's about the motivation
you might need to actually sell people
as to how it helps them grow and why
it's beneficial to the business as well
so you need to take all of these things
into account as to the style of how you
work with people and even for the same
person for a different task you'll need
a different style and this is kind of
what this model is talking about I
talked a little bit about sort of
uniqueness and strengths before and one
of the my favorite books is this book
called strengths finder so it was
written by the Gallup Organization or
somebody who worked for the Gallup
Organization and they've catalogued 34
different signature strengths and when
you do this book you get you're sort of
top five strengths what that also means
is there's a whole bunch of strengths
you don't have the great thing is
working in a team you have people who
have complementary strengths to yourself
that you can all tap into for the right
type of reasons so as an example one of
the strengths that they talk about is
whoo you probably know some people at
this stands for winning others over
right they're people that can walk into
a room sell an idea and suddenly they've
like convinced people to do this it's
very rare but like those people are
really powerful influencers in
organizations where you need to champion
idea get some change across or get
people you know on board for an idea um
you have people that are strategic so
people who have the strength when
they're not thinking about now but
they're thinking about where are we
gonna be in a year or two years time do
we invest in kubernetes or do we ignore
that and do we go straight to server
lists right you have people who are
thinking about this and focused on that
most businesses also need something like
an achiever
you can't have people that are only just
strategizing you need people who are
executing and I would actually say
inside a plan do you have a lot of
achievers because you know you have this
get stuff done mentality you know I
manage I have got the strength of
achiever and you can recognize this
because I love to write lists and then
cross them out all right so if you have
this this is like the achiever thing you
get sense the pleasure of like crossing
off something saying I've done something
I've done another thing I've done that
thing right you get that sense of
progress and then you also have people
who are you know intellection strength
and these are people who love to ponder
about a problem and this is where
sometimes you think about this is a
sense of sort of conflict but I would
say it's actually a sense of empathy as
well so when I was pair programming with
people and they had an intellectual
strategic and there's another strength
called analytical people need more time
to digest a problem and I would get a
little bit frustrated because like
achiever me would be like let's do
something let's write a test let's make
it fail and you know we started to bump
into like some conflict because you know
I thought okay well they just don't get
why we're doing this thing this book
helped me understand it wasn't about
them or myself it was about different
strengths and we started to recognize
actually we have different styles of
approaching a problem and that actually
helped us improve working relationships
because I started to recognize these
things and say hey I get it you need
some time let's splitter away from
pairing for a bit you do some thinking I
will play around with some code and then
we'll come back together and then we'll
think about how do we combine our
approaches right and this is actually a
really good way of empathizing about
where people come from and explaining
habits that might annoy you it's not
because people are different they have
different strengths and that's something
that you need to appreciate and I'm not
the only person that has like done
research so really recent research was
from BCG and they tried to understand
what are the elements of diversity that
improve revenue and they talked about
specifically innovation revenue so
inventions creations they actually
inspected six different elements and
they actually found that four of them so
surprisingly not age and not to
education has an impact on innovation
but gender the country of origin the
industry where people come from and the
types of career paths that people have
been through mean that you have
different creative solving problem
Roach's that you can actually tap into
that help you innovate now anyone in a
leadership role will know time
management is really hard and so this is
where actually you have to get really
good at managing your time one of my
favorite sort of tools is this quadrant
and it helps you really understand where
you should spend time so for instance
there's things that are less important
and less urgent all those slack
notifications checking them every five
minutes Twitter every notification you
get on Twitter do you need to go log in
these are things that are not so
important not so urgent you should sort
of stop doing that so I know some people
that say I'll only check email twice a
day or I'll only check slap twice a day
between these hours if it's really
urgent I'm sure you can come and find me
alright so if it is really urgent there
are ways to get in contact find your
flow and that's really important for
things that are less important but it
urgent this is where you can actually
delegate it to people right so if people
get it wrong then it probably isn't
gonna have a big impact if it's wrong
the first time and it gives people an
opportunity to grow and contribute to
something very important and obviously
the things that are important and urgent
those production outages incidents you
need to act on it immediately but the
interesting quadrant that often gets
left out is this thing that is important
but less urgent and these are the things
that nobody asks you to do right these
are the things that you're responsible
for but nobody is actively asking you
for a plan of what is your technical
bird one how are you dealing with your
architecture as it revolves these are
things that you have to work out what is
important and where you find time to
discuss this with the team and this is
where you need to decide to make time in
your calendar to make sure you think
about this so in my calendar I would
normally have planning blocks and as
part of those planning box I would
refuse meetings and this is exactly what
I was trying to do carve out time for
those important but less urgent things
so fine if there was something that
needed to be dealt with that was urgent
I could deal with it but I need to make
sure that I had time to think about am i
adding the most value as a leader to
help amplify the success of the team and
you need to make the time to work out
what's important for you nobody will
often tell you that this matrix actually
is called the Eisenhower matrix after
an Eisenhower and there's a lot of sort
of reading about this but the summary of
this kind of section is really thinking
about you know need to take a mental
model shift from moving from maker to
multiplier so you no longer get rewarded
for the things that you produce as an
individual it becomes less concrete you
have to appreciate the value that your
whole team creates and it's less output
driven as a result and you need to sort
of take the shifts from being a maker
and become a multiplier so we've gone on
this journey try to understand some of
the different stories what is the tech
lead spices and Ruggles and hopefully
you have some tools to make you a much
more effective tech lead some of the
keys to growth that we talked about that
I want to sort of summarize are making
sure that you recognize that as you go
on this journey that this tech lead role
is a role change it requires different
skills and strengths things you will
have accumulated experience points for
but you need to develop those experience
points it requires these leadership
skills that often organisations will not
have given you training and support for
and so you need to find ways to actually
grow them for yourself but the good
thing is that other people have been on
this journey and that there are many
other resources out there so build your
support network talk to people about how
they approach things find new ways of
adding more to your sort of toolkit and
make sure you practice some of these
things and the final lesson is really
making sure you take this mental model
shift from moving from maker to
multiplier mode so thank you very much I
think we're out of time but I'll stay
around for questions if you like I don't
wanna hold you back from lunch and if
you also want we have some sort of
laptop security covers which are very
good if you like to have privacy from
your camera thank you very much
[Applause]
yes
so the pupils I don't know if you come
across Simon Brown